comment vois-tu casimir qu'est ce que ça
va si vous m'avez fait peur je vais très
bien je vous remercie et et vous comment
tu arrives à joué merveilleusement bien
dans casimir te dire que je me suis
réveillé l'âme poète et depuis ce matin
j'étais impatient de venir dans le
jardin pour écrire un petit bijou de
poèmes là assis sur ce banc au milieu
des oiseaux sous le soleil est entourée
de tous mes amis et bien je suis très
content pour vous je vous laisse
travailler tranquille à tout à leur
mercie casimir à tout à l'heure
bon voyons voyons voyons voyons voyons
il est noir non il fait noir oui walaa
merveilleux voilà le petit jeu de paume
qui commence il fait noir il fait noir
comme c'est agréable de travailler dans
ce jardin calme et tranquille
excusez moi monsieur du cinéma
pardon je ne voudrais pas vous déranger
mais je ne veux pas troubler votre
inspiration ni vous ennuyer oui je
voulais autre kazemi reçoit bref s'il te
plaît parce que je ne pourrai jamais
trouver la fin de mon poème
vous savez quand je vous aime beaucoup
et que nous sommes maintenant de grands
amis ça c'est vrai c'est content que tu
l'aies compris je voulais également vous
dire quand je vous trouve grâce à un
pack qui devrait aussi les souabes raide
que ses murs et bien voilà je je je suis
très content que vous me tutoyez se
contenta plaisir casimir oui je trouve
ça très agréable
je suis enchanté casimir mais pour
l'amour du ciel soit terminé mon petit
bijou de peau elle moment très bien je
voulais savoir c'est ça c'est ça ou un
étage ah oui il fait noir
ah ça c'est très bien fait très beau et
puis c'est simple il fait noir
tout le monde connaît je tu il
il fait il fait chaud il fait froid
non il fait noir ah non à la plus belle
des couleurs c'est merveilleux monsieur
du snarr qu'y at il encore dit
moi oui j'ai réfléchi est ce possible
oui je couvrais beaucoup plus simple si
je vous tutoyait moi aussi c'est
absolument impossible
vraiment vraiment mon rang ma naissance
ou l'éducation au savoir ne le
permettent pas je comprends c'est
dommage au revoir au revoir
nous on est un jeu ah oui il fait noir
et comme c'est agréable de dire il c'est
noir il peignoir bois à c'est simple il
suffisait d'y penser c'est moi 19 qui a
pensé c'est absolument délicieux c'est
très embêtant c'est même une catastrophe
monsieur du snav moi tu toi et moi je le
vouvoie si bien que les gens vont penser
qu'il m'est supérieur qu'il est plus
intelligent ou ou même plus beau que moi
ce qui n'est pas vrai du tout non non il
faut qu' il faut qu'ils me vouvoie
également je vais arranger ça c'est pas
possible
monsieur listenable que se passe t'il
encore je souhaiterais que vous me
vouvoyer comme autrefois comme tu veux
casimir et pour l'amour dit seles mois
travaillés mais non monsieur disque ne
pas me laisser travailler
messi mais vous avez dit comme tu veux
casimir alors bien alors il fallait dire
comme vous voulez casimir bon si tu veux
si tu veux je dirai ce que tu voudras
pour que tu me laisses finir vos poèmes
mais non vous ne comprenez rien du tout
bon bon bon j'ai compris et casimir
décidé de demandes juillet de mon péché
signer mon poème j'ai compris très bien
mais pas du tout enfin quand on tutoie
les gens on leur dit tu es si on voulait
vous voyez on leur vie vous c'est pas
compliqué et pourtant c'est si beau il
fait noir il fait noir où il fait noir
mais alors s'il fait noir c'est le soir
il faut que je rentre chez moi à temps
casimir toutu répéter ce que tu veux te
dire s'il te plaît g10 il fait noir
c'est le soir c'est évident mais oui
c'est sans merveilleux casimir merci
c'était donc il était noir
c'est le soir à s'immiscer tu veux te
ferai
grand plaisir de mettre ton verre dans
nos problèmes aussi vous voulez je feins
le poème pour femmes
non non c'est absolument impossible mais
tu peux peut-être mais d un tir le poème
ça je serais ravi de travailler avec
vous même ans et kazimiya carte
très sincèrement je pense que ton génie
créateur complète parfaitement le mien
et quand on aura terminé on invitera
juillet françois et nous leur dirons
notre au chef-d'oeuvre il sera génial
casimir écouter seulement il ya une
petite condition oui on la gîte
j'ai un marché à vous proposer
[Musique]
françois vite que ce que je viens de
recevoir un mot de casimir me demandant
de réunir tous les enfants et les
personnes susceptibles d'apprécier la
bonne poésie de la poésie
bien vite il ne va pas tarder à arriver
formidable les enfants venez vite avec
nous sur le banc installez vous venez
venez vite vous allez voir ça va être
formidable
casimir va nous dire ah ben voilà
monsieur des snobs et avec lui bonjour
bonjour vous êtes nous sommes prêts mais
vient d'installer allez-y monsieur li
chn abord je peux commencer je vous en
prie mon chat casimir tentant françois
monsieur 10 me badie vous à casimir cher
public adoré
voici un poème composé de droit propre
et un post scriptum que je ne mets pas
si li té première ostroff enfin il fait
noir c'est le soir
bassan passe pas sans penser sans penser
qu'il fait noir et qu'il passe dans le
soir
un chien le regard de partie le regarde
pas c'est comme une vache se regarde un
train passer et pourtant le chien
n'était pas varaschin et le passant pas
entre ça ne fait rien le pass l'autre
regarde deuxième strophe
je regardais pont s'est passé c'est la
vie regardez pensé passer et l'habiller
passé nous parle troisième strophe la
morale de cette histoire est qu'armand
alia c'est qu'en passant on ne pense pas
passé dont sans penser que l'histoire
est possible post scriptum
ouf guérini je félicite mon vieux du
snob
tu as été formidable oh non non je peux
supporter pourtant tu m'avais promis
c'est différent mais c'est pas pour
monsieur du snuff votre poème était très
bon mais ce n'est pas ça tu ne va pas
pleurer devant nous je vous en prie
kazemi expliquez-nous
mais pourquoi pourquoi il a accepté
non j'aurais pas v'nu ce n'était pouvant
taha je la comprends aux rémois n'ont
pris que je suis malheureux mais chez
les jeunes expliquez vous maintenant on
sait trop par eux quasi mien m'a tutoyé
vous comprenez il m'a dit mais qu'est ce
que ça ne tutoie pas monsieur young il
déteste ça oh mais ça ne fait rien c'est
bien fait nous avons fait un marché
marché
mais oui il n'arrivait pas à écrire le
poème tout seul alors je les écris à sa
place mais en échange il doit me
vouvoyer toute la journée
et moi je le tutoie mais pourquoi tiens
tu absolument à tutoyer monsieur du snob
parce que c'est beaucoup mieux pour te
traiter de pau est minable
kelly